-Our next guest is a
Grammy-award winning musician,
one of the most successful
female acts ever,
with over 80 million records
sold worldwide.
Her signature collection
of wines
are now available to buy
in the U.S.
Please welcome back to the show
Kylie Minogue, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hi, Kylie!
-Wow!
-Thank you for being here,
and thank you
for bringing some wine.
Would you like
some of your rosé?
-Yes.
-All right, great.
Here's a bottle,
a beautiful bottle of your rosé.
-Thank you.
-And here's yours.
-Why aren't
all TV chat shows like this?
-I know! Well, nobody's
polite enough to bring wine.
-Cheers to you all.
-Cheers to you guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is absolutely lovely.
-Mmm!
-Now, I have a lot of questions.
I have a lot of questions
about your wine.
But I also want
to ask about this.
When was this performance
with Coldplay?
It was this trip
when you were out here?
-Yeah, it was
a couple nights ago.
-So you're at MetLife Stadium,
and Coldplay reaches out
and asks you to do a song?
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughs ]
And what do you say?
Yes.
-Wow!
That's fantastic.
And so you -- I mean, no one
knew you were gonna be there,
and you walk out and --
-I barely knew I was gonna be.
This is a reach-out
the day before.
And I know the guys.
I've known them for a long time.
-Yes. But they just --
When the word gets to them
that you're in town?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Wow!
-But the thing is,
I banned myself from seeing
the rest of the show,
because I've got
a performance myself tonight,
actually, and I knew if
I watched the Coldplay show,
I would sing, scream, yell,
dance, ruin myself.
So, love Coldplay,
performed with Coldplay,
but didn't see it.
I banned myself.
-Wow!
-Yeah, I'll see them
another time, when I can
really let loose.
-What was the inspiration
for Kylie Minogue
having her own wine?
-It's pretty simple, actually.
I love a good glass of wine.
And when I was recording
in Nashville, of all places,
a few years back,
it was peak summer, boiling hot,
and Nashville
work sensible hours,
sensible songwriting hours.
So each night
was al fresco dining
in the heat
with a glass of rosé.
And one night,
the light was coming through it,
and I just said, "I'd love
to have my own rosé one day,"
and a few years later, I do.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, so it's
a pretty thrilling industry.
It's all new to me.
I'm learning as I go along.
-And I don't think a pandemic
was good for anyone,
but I feel like people
who are selling wine
maybe did all right.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, weirdly, I met with
the team I work with March 2020,
so we actually developed
the range
on the doorstep, pretty much.
My house, they'd drop off --
here's the bottles,
here's the juice,
here's the labels,
you put them all together.
And yeah, I thought,
"Does this work?"
releasing a wine
at that point in time?
And actually, it did.
-Yeah.
-There you go.
I think people were looking
to have something to drink,
and you were somebody
they trusted.
So that's...
-Yeah, yeah.
-So, we have photos from your
first time in New York City.
So...
-Okay, let's just get it
out of the way.
Let's deal with 1988.
-All right, 1988.
[ Laughter ]
Now you have --
this is "Loco-Motion," right?
-I thought you were gonna say,
"You have a perm."
-[ Laughs ]
Well, you have a perm.
-Which I may have.
-So I think that this is --
this is really lovely, because
obviously, your first time here,
you might have thought this was
a fancy part of the city.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, look at the junk.
That's amazing.
No one thought to clean that up.
-But now this is crazy --
you have had --
in five decades,
you have had a number-one hit
in every decade
for the last five decades.
-I've had a number-one album
in five decades.
-Number-one album, excuse me.
I'm selling you short.
-I know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, and I guess
the weird thing is, I was --
A couple of years ago --
I was 52 --
so I had to do the math.
Like, okay --
five decades
with five number-ones.
But, you know,
it was the late '80s
to the start of the 2020s.
-Well, it's pretty amazing.
-Yeah, I mean,
it's mind-blowing.
I didn't know
when I was that age
and that girl
that I would have this...
-Yeah.
-...these opportunities.
-And you were like,
"Why are they putting me
in whatever this machine is?"
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I have a real memory of you.
You were the musical guest
at "SNL."
It was my first year
on the show,
and Ian McKellen was the host.
-I didn't know
that was your first year.
-And he was the happiest
I've ever seen
as a host introducing
a musical guest.
And for years, we would --
someone would just,
out of nowhere say,
"Ladies and gentlemen,
you lucky, lucky people,
Kylie Minogue!"
-Yeah.
-He was so happy.
-I remember he was perched
on the side of the stage
just like --
How to be more nervous on "SNL."
Ian McKellen right there.
But he was kind of...
Yeah, he's very generous.
-He came by it honestly.
He was genuinely excited.
It was the only time that,
during the song,
they cut to the host,
sitting on the side of the
stage, watching, and I'm like...
-Yeah. I'll take it.
That's great.
-I was like,
"Kylie might have means
to have
a restraining order filed."
[ Laughter ]
So this is -- Obviously,
you've been very successful,
but this is a photo of you
with Conor McGregor.
And this was very --
this helped your success
with your nieces and nephews.
-Well, I have three nephews,
and once in a while --
I mean,
that was a totally random --
We look so happy there.
-You look so happy.
This is a recent photo --
-I was happy.
He looks very happy.
-[ Laughs ]
-I just bumped into him
after the "Elvis" premiere
in Cannes, as you do.
[ Laughter ]
Some things roll off the tongue.
-You know, you're at Cannes,
and you meet Conor McGregor.
We've all been there.
-And, yes, and my three nephews
are 11, 13, and 16.
Prime.
So I get the message
from one of them going,
"You met Conor McGregor?"
Like, there's so many moments
that I don't think
they're gonna travel that far,
but I was excited.
But my nephews were peaking.
-And this is a photo --
I also think this is very cool.
Conor McGregor asked for
the photo with you, correct?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And you're --
-But given a minute,
I might've asked, as well.
[ Laughter ]
-This is also cool.
-It's almost like we checked
what each other
was gonna wear there.
-I know.
It really does look like
you arranged it in advanced.
So, this is really cool.
So there's an Australian soap
called "Neighbours,"
and I'm aware of the show
because I feel like
almost every Australian
who has succeeded started there.
-Yeah.
-And they're having a finale.
This is it.
They're wrapping it up after...?
-After 30-something --
I don't know how -- 37 years.
I don't know.
Long enough. Long enough.
-This is the show that you got
your break on, right?
Your first time?
-Yeah, my first kind of --
I started acting
when I was 11, 16.
When I was 19, I finished
school, signed up for the Dole
'cause I thought,
"I'm never gonna get a job,"
but I got this role
on "Neighbours,"
and that was in 1986.
-Wow.
-So, I was only in the show
for 2 1/2 years,
but it's when it just exploded.
Like, you know, England,
they just went crazy about it.
And so it's been with me
ever since,
and it's a large part of how I
entered into the music industry.
And, you know,
you're in people's households.
The show was played twice a day,
actually, and people would
bunk off school, they'd leave --
they'd change the office hours.
It was a huge thing, because
whoever knew how to set the VHS?
Yeah, so they're finishing
the show,
and there was quite
a bit of pressure for me
to go back, so I shot my scenes.
-You went back!
You went back for the finale.
Oh, very cool.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And another friend you may have
had on the show, Guy Pearce.
-Yes.
-He was in the same show,
so he's just filmed
his little return, as well.
So we're all gonna cry.
-Oh, that's wonderful.
I'm so glad you did that.
Thank you so much
for bringing the wine
and being here with us today.
-Thank you!
-I really appreciate it.
-Nice seeing you.
-Kylie Minogue, everybody.
For more information
on her wine,
visit KylieMinogueWines.com.
We'll be right back
with Leila Mottley.